[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american absurdist
comedy drama film called everything
everywhere all at once spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the protagonist evelyn wang is a chinese
american who came to the u.s long ago
with her husband weymond the couple runs
a laundromat which has been struggling
for the past few years it is currently
being audited by the irs and is at risk
of being closed evelyn's life has not
turned out how she wanted it to her
daughter joy is in a lesbian
relationship that she doesn't approve of
and her husband weymond is seeking to
get a divorce in their loveless marriage
moreover she is soon being visited by
her father gong who never wanted her to
leave china in the following scene
evelyn waymond and her father go to the
irs office to submit the papers related
to their business the three get on an
elevator when something strange happens
a force hits raymond and makes him act
strange his demeanor changes entirely
almost as if he is changed into a
different person he turns towards his
wife and tells her that her life is in
danger he doesn't have much time to
explain because the real waymond will
come back to his body in a second he
makes her wear a headset and gives her a
set of notes to follow once he is gone
the headset starts working and shows him
a panel on his phone then something
strange happens to evelyn she remembers
every single thing that has ever
happened to her from her birth to how
she left chyna to the birth of her
daughter and how they drifted apart
suddenly raymond comes back to his
normal self leaving evelyn utterly
confused they go to the irs officer
deirdre and show her the income and
expenditure file she is not happy about
the unnecessary purchases made in the
name of their business their shop is on
the verge of being frozen but all evelyn
can think of is what happened earlier
she brings the paper out which asks her
to switch her shoes to the wrong feet
close her eyes and imagine herself in
the janitor's closet when she does so
her entire reality changes evelyn is
able to make a second version of herself
whose consciousness is inside the
janitor's closet with a different
weymouth she is in two places at the
same time much to her astonishment
raymond then explains the truth about
the multiverse in reality the world is a
cluster of several universes called the
multiverse there are trillions of earths
in trillions of universes that exist
close to ours on every earth lives a
different version of a person one can be
a doctor a pilot an animal or even a
rock similarly this weymouth belongs to
the universe named alpha it is the most
advanced universe so far and the one
that discovered the concept of the
multiverse in alpha earth evelyn is a
scientist who found out a way to make
one's consciousness travel into a
different universe using the same
process alpha weymond transferred his
consciousness into the weymouth of this
world evelyn still doesn't know what he
is or why he has come to her alpha
weymond replies that the entire world is
at the risk of being destroyed by their
daughter joy in the alpha world joy was
the most talented bouncer who could
exist in several universes at a time
evelyn pushed her limits and made a
malfunction in the system which gave joy
the power to exist in every single
universe at once she gained knowledge
about trillions of versions of herself
and came to the conclusion that nothing
matters the world is a lie and humans
are just a pack of misery to end this
misery and gain eternal peace she
created a black hole called the
everything bagel black hole she wants to
suck the multiverse inside and end
everything to ever exist the only person
who can stop joy is evelyn hence joy is
going into universes one after another
to kill all versions of her mother this
version of evelyn is the saddest one so
far she hasn't done anything significant
in her life or in her career unlike all
other versions of herself who are
successful to some level hence alpha
weymouth believes that she is the one
out of trillions of evolence who will
help to save the multiverse alpha joy is
evil and is sending several people to
kill evelyn hence she should immediately
learn to defend herself in some
universes evelyn is a martial arts
expert if she jumps into one such
universe she will be able to learn the
skills instantly which will help further
her fight right then they are attacked
by joy's minions who have found out
where alpha weymouth is deirdre also
attacks them having been taken over by
her alpha version in the middle of the
fight evelyn jumps universes for the
first time looking for a universe where
she is a martial arts expert however she
accidentally reaches a universe in the
future where she and her husband are
discussing their divorce evelyn jumps
back to the world and tries for a second
time fortunately for her this time she
reaches the universe where she is an
expert fighter in this reality she chose
to stay in china rather than come to the
u.s with waymond she eventually grew up
to become an expert in martial arts and
a highly successful actress she lives
that life for a few seconds and then
returns to the original world evelyn can
almost not believe that one single
decision made such a harsh difference in
her life but before she can overthink
the mistake she is attacked by deirdre
she beats her ass this time having
learned everything that the actress
version of herself knew when everything
calms down alpha weymond asks her to eat
while she is at it she again envisions
herself in the world where she is an
actress in an event alpha weymouth comes
to meet her without her he has also
become a successful businessman they
reunite after years but the spark
between them is still present alva
weymond brings her out of her dreams
because they have to get away before the
evil joy arrives what they do not know
is that joy has taken over evelyn's
daughter and is already inside the
building alpha raymond loses connection
and returns to his own world leaving
evelyn alone a few minutes later evelyn
meets the evil joy dressed in her
signature funky clothing she has the
power to manifest and change anything
about all universes she causes a
policeman to turn into confetti and
starts performing a salsa dance with the
other she also fights a man using adult
toys leaving evelyn and probably the
audience in utter shock after defeating
everyone else she walks towards evelyn
ready to kill her as well just then
evelyn makes a jump to a universe where
she can learn more fighting skills
however she ends up in a place where
people have hot dogs for fingers in this
world she is in a relationship with
deirdre who loves to watch people eat
each other's fingers get me the hell out
of this place because of this mistake
she is about to be killed but is saved
by alpha gong a while later all the
alphas disappear leaving joy and weymon
confused evelyn tries explaining
everything to them but the two do not
believe in her absurd stories by now the
evil joy has taken many people under her
control and is making them attack the
family evelyn goes into different
realities to acquire all knowledge that
the different versions of herself know
she finds herself to be a blind woman a
singer a cook an artist and a street
artist for a pizza company all in
different universes using the skills of
all the versions she is able to defeat
everyone in one go in the end she is
exhausted and is held by the alpha
weymond back on the alpha planet joy
gets to her father and kills him as a
result he dies in evelynn's arms as well
leaving only the original waymond behind
following that joy comes to evelyn again
confident that no one will stop her this
time evelyn tries going into more
universes but it makes her sick joy
laughs at her and leaves her to die in
the next scene evelyn wakes up as the
actress watching the premiere of her new
film she simultaneously wakes up as a
cook in the movie rakakui where the rat
is a raccoon being in so many realities
at once is too hard for her to take
suddenly everything shuts down and she
goes back to her future self who is in
her office after the meeting at the irs
they are preparing for the chinese new
year celebration evelyn runs to joy and
asks her if she is fine she soon figures
out the person she is talking to is the
evil joy the mother and daughter face
each other in different realities even
in the one where they are both born as
pinatas in the process evelyn also goes
through the same malfunction that made
joy evil she meets every single version
of herself and realizes that nothing
matters in every life she is miserable
in one way or the other and the same
goes for everyone who is ever born
evelyn finally understands why her
daughter wants to end everything and
sides with her in the following scene we
are shown another reality where the
mother and daughter are rocks on a cliff
they chat through telepathy and tell
each other that even in a life as a rock
they are miserable they decide that
there is no point in the world's
existence so they should end it as a
whole the two are finally in front of
the everything bagel black hole ready to
sacrifice themselves at this moment
evelyn gets an epiphany she focuses on
herself who is currently in her
laundromat deirdre has come with the
police to arrest her for tax fraud and
the chaos she caused at the irs office
today she is handcuffed while her
husband talks to deirdre trying to
convince her to let them go he finally
convinces her and they get a week to
submit the proper audit of the shop he
then comes to his wife assuring her
everything will be fine this makes
evelyn realize there are some things in
life that do matter little things that
make it worth living unlike what she had
thought earlier in the reality where she
is an actress she and weymond meet in an
alley after the movie premiere there are
a lot of things holding them back from
being together but evelyn brushes them
aside and declares that they should date
likewise in the hot dog hands reality
she and deirdre solve their differences
and live as a happy couple in all
trillion universes evelyn finds
something that is worth the life they
live and hence she hugs weymond refusing
to go into the black hole with the evil
joy joy sends an army of people to
attack her but evelyn makes them
understand the revelation that she just
had in the end they are also convinced
that life is worth living however joy
does not feel the same she walks toward
the black hole to end herself in another
reality evelyn introduces joy's
girlfriend to her father not ashamed of
her daughter anymore they mend their
relationship and embrace each other in a
last hug as a result the evil joy also
comes to terms with the reality of life
even if the entire world is against you
there is always one thing or one person
who makes life worth living evelyn
weymond and gong collectively pull evil
joy out of the bagel and bring her back
to her normal self the scene then cuts
to a week later the family is outside
the irs office to submit the final draft
of the audit they have accepted joy's
girlfriend as a part of their family and
joy couldn't be happier evelyn and
weymond were about to get a divorce but
the incidents have made their love
stronger than ever evelyn listens to him
and respects him as she did years ago
deirdre gets a look at the final audit
and approves it it turns out that the
family is just bad at doing taxes only
because they don't understand the big
words in the documents the movie ends as
evelyn looks at her family with pride
she is finally happy with how her life
turned out even after knowing many other
possibilities she could have become
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching